there it is a natural disaster that just
keeps repeating itself
so we followed the smoke you can follow
it live with the maps and satellites
from Brazil's Environment Agency it's a
service part funded by the UK you can
see when it's done through here of the
course the last few weeks and we came
off the main road because we saw this
huge plume above us and the area that's
burning has put another mile or so in
that direction this land is supposed to
be permanently protected the warnings
are here but firefighters have told us
that around 90% of the fires in the
Amazon region this summer are man-made
it's a long empty walk in if you get
closer you just hear it crackling away
it keeps popping up in different
sections
there are trees falling all around us
and this is what deforestation looks
like up close there is nobody here there
is nobody to stop it and it just goes on
for mile after mile the dry season
always means wildfires but in this one
state alone there have been five and a
half thousand fires just this month and
seven states in Brazil have asked for
emergency help the motive for all this
isn't far away farmers want more land to
exploit and have felt emboldened by
Brazil's right-wing government
environmentalists like Luciana are
dismayed door-key
I am here watching all these and asking
for help we the people who live here are
asking for help
what is your impression of how the
Brazilian government are dealing with
this not a lead on do they are not
dealing with it the Brazilian government
is responsible for it the Brazilian
government has helped start this
violence they triggered the attitude of
those criminals the president of Brazil
strongly denies that his policies are to
blame he sent in the military to fight
the fires and has brought in
international help but it's happening
like this across borders across the
continent the wilderness is being eaten
up Tom Parmenter Sky News northern
Brazil